Diana gets the dog
5 canine cookies for one frisbee catch
and 3 canine cookies per grip on a ball.
Sounds like a very bargain deal.
She plans to get the most
D dog cookies before latching a queue.
Okay, that sounds good.
The inequality graph below
represents the set of all combinations,
in which Diana takes F Frisbee and B balls,
to get the most D cookies,
because at this point she reasonably starts to queue the tail.
According to the chart we'll look at in a second,
what is the largest number of cookies,
which Diana wants to get before queues?
In other words, how much is D?
Let's interpret this graph correctly.
If we look at the horizontal axis here,
this is F - the number of Frisbee,
the number of Frisbee she catches.
The number of balls is a vertical axis.
The number of balls she catches.
And we know what the total number of cookies is.
If she grabs F on Frisbee,
will receive 5 cookies for each,
so cookies in the Frisbee are 5F.
If she catches B in number of balls,
or bring B balls if she catches those B balls,
will get ... how many were they? Three?
Three ball cookies? Yes!
Three canine cookies to capture each ball.
The B balls are 3B.
So the total number of cookies,
which she receives is 5F plus 3B.
This is the number of Frisbee cookies,
and this is the number of balls cookies.
Now we can see all the allowed combinations here
of the number of Frisbee and number of balls.
For example, at this point here - 8,
i. if you catch or bring 8 balls,
and catch ... it will be half a frisbee,
so this does not seem meaningful.
But if he brings 8 balls and grabs 1 frisbee ...
Ok, that's it ..
It still does not reach
the maximum number of cookies.
How do I find the maximum number of cookies?
The maximum number of cookies
is at each of these points,
who find themselves in the right, and notes that decisions,
where all the points that meet this inequality lie,
are all under this right,
so it reaches the maximum when it is on the right
and the easiest one might be this point here,
where we see that the Frisbee is zero and we have 10 balls,
which increases to the maximum number of cookies.
If she grabs 10 balls, let me record it,
if B = 10, F is 0.
If F equals 0 and B equals 10,
how many cookies will I receive?
She will receive - this will be 0
and then 3 in 10 is 30,
so there are 30 cookies.
Hence this point here
corresponds to 30 cookies.
You can see that each of these points
along this blue line corresponds to 30 cookies.
If you go here at F = 6
... let me write it here:
F = 6 and B = 0,
Diana uses all her time,
she earns the cookies entirely
from catching frisbee,
so this is the situation where F = 6 and B = 0,
Just once more,
when F is 6, 5 by 6 is 30, plus 3 by 0,
these are 30 cookies.
So the maximum, or the number of cookies,
which he needs before starting to queue, is 30.
Therefore, D will be 30
and we can express this inequality as
5F + 3B is less than or equal to 30.
Okay, then ask another thing.
Can Diana fulfill her plan,
taking 4 Frisbee and 2 Balls?
Let's see 4 Frisbee and 2 Balls ...
That's right here - 4 Frisbee and 2 Balls.
Here we are not saying,
that she must take the maximum of 30 cookies,
but simply can not eat more than 30 cookies.
It seems she can do her plan to see.
The inequality chart below presents all combinations,
in which Diana takes F Frisbee and B balls,
to get the most D cookies.
So, to see, will she do her plan by grabbing ...
well yes, I would say yes.